- If you were following the trial
of Kyle Rittenhouse on social media,
you might've come to the conclusion
that Judge Schroeder was a
hopelessly biased nutcase
who was making up all the rules
to help Kyle Rittenhouse.
Was he?
(gentle music)
Now most of the situations
that people are objecting to involve
the application of the rules of evidence.
In state court, the judge
has broad discretion
to make rulings on the
admissibility of evidence
and how to run their courtroom.
This includes things like which witnesses
are allowed to testify,
what the lawyers are allowed to ask,
what topics are off limits,
and a whole bunch of other things.
And there were a few
incidents that stuck out.
So let's talk about incident number one,
where Judge Schroeder ruled
that the prosecution
could not call the people
that Kyle Rittenhouse
shot and killed victims.
The defense attorneys argue
that using the word victim
could prejudice the jury
against Rittenhouse.
Judge Schroeder said, "The word victim
is a loaded, loaded word."
When the judge ruled in
favor of the defendant,
critics jumped to the conclusion
that Judge Schroeder was showing
inappropriate favoritism to Rittenhouse.
Now trial judges have lots of discretion.
The Wisconsin rules of evidence
mostly track the federal
rules of evidence.
Even if particular evidence
isn't explicitly ruled out,
judges have lots of leeway.
Wisconsin rule of evidence 904.03,
which is very similar
to federal rule of evidence 403 states,
"Although relevant,
evidence may be excluded
if its probative value is
substantially outweighed
by the danger of unfair prejudice,
confusion of the issues,
or misleading the jury,
or by considerations of undue delay,
waste of time, or needless presentation
of cumulative evidence."
In other words, evidence
might be minimally relevant,
but if the risk of prejudice is too great,
you shouldn't allow that
evidence into the courtroom.
And the way that the victim
is used in a courtroom
is different than what's used
outside of the courthouse.
Rittenhouse claimed that he
was acting in self-defense.
If he was right, the three men
would not be considered victims
in the legal sense of the word.
They would be assailants
who attacked Rittenhouse.
People also suggested that Judge Schroeder
was making a special rules
just for Rittenhouse,
but the judge's ruling was consistent
with the way that he
handles criminal trials.
According to the Kenosha News,
"that is Schroeder standard practice
in criminal cases and is not unique
to this handling of the Rittenhouse case."
Criminal lawyers said these rulings
were commonplace in their
jurisdictions as well.
Victims suggest guilt before it is proven
and prosecuting and
convicting someone is hard,
as well it should be.
And of course, it's always okay to refer
to these people by their names,
which tactically can be even better
because it humanizes them.
In a court of law, a criminal defendant
must be given his full due process rights.
The whole object of a fair trial
is not to prejudge the defendant.
That means judges should
be skeptical of evidence
that a jury could use to
infer someone's guilt,
if that evidence is not truly
probative of what happened.
And that brings us to the second incidence
where Judge Schroeder ruled
that the three men who were shot
could be referred to as
rioters, looters, and arsonists.
Well, specifically what
Judge Schroeder said
was let the evidence show
what the evidence shows,
that any or one of these people
were engaged in arson,
rioting, or looting,
that I'm not going to tell the defense
they can't call them that.
Prosecutor Thomas Binger said
that this was a double standard.
"I think it's the exact same issue.
The terms that I'm identifying here,
such as rioters, looters, arsonists,
are as loaded, if not more
loaded, than the term victim."
First, a defendant
generally gets to put on
whatever defense they want.
So a court should err on the side
of allowing a defendant to do something
and get more freedom than the prosecution.
But second of all, Judge
Schroeder did not rule
that the defense could
absolutely call them
rioters and looters.
He ruled that if the defense could prove
that the three men were
rioting and looting,
then they could use those terms
during the closing argument.
And the judge prohibited the defense
from using those terms during
their opening statement,
very similar to the ruling he
made about the word victim.
Neither side could use those terms
unless they prove their case.
That takes us to incident number three,
where Judge Schroeder dressed down
the prosecutor saying,
"Don't get brazen with me!"
Judge Schroeder was again accused of bias
when he blew up at
Prosecutor Thomas Binger.
First of all, yes,
judges do yell at lawyers
and sometimes those lawyers deserve it.
Some do it more frequently than others.
And Kenosha lawyers say that Schroeder
is definitely a yeller.
Now second, the judge sent
the jury out of the room
before admonishing the prosecutor.
And third, and most importantly,
we should look to what caused
Schroeder to blow his top.
When Rittenhouse took to the stand
to testify in his own defense,
the prosecutor seemed to refer
to Rittenhouse's prior
silence about what happened.
"Since August 25th, 2020,
this is the first time that
you have told your story."
That's what the prosecutor
asked on the stand.
The defense immediately objected
and Schroeder sustained the objection,
disallowing the question.
And there's good reason for that.
In criminal cases, the
5th Amendment protects
against self-incrimination,
among other things.
This means that a defendant's
decision not to talk
can't be used against them.
The judge sustained the objection
because Binger's question
was too close to the line.
But then Binger basically asked
the same question a different way.
He referred to the many months of people
talking about the case and said,
"After all of that now,
you are telling us your
side of the story, correct?"
It seems that what Binger was getting at
was that because Rittenhouse
hadn't testified before
and was now testifying after everyone else
had taken the stand, and
after all of the evidence
had come out, that Rittenhouse was now
in a position where he
could change his story
and craft it to be consistent
with everyone else's testimony.
But, of course, a question
can be two things at once.
And if it's too prejudicial,
even if there is some
probative value to it,
well, then the court
can still disallow it,
which the court specifically had done it.
Schroeder had disallowed it.
So Judge Schroeder asked
to the jury be removed
so that he could basically
just yell at Binger.
- You need to account for this.
The problem is, this is a
grave constitutional violation
for you to talk about
the defendant's silence.
And that is, and you're right,
you're right on the borderline.
And you may be over.
But it better stop.
- In other words, it doesn't matter
whether you think
Rittenhouse was guilty or not
in the context of a criminal trial,
his post-arrest silence
couldn't be used against him.
Binger said he understood,
but then to add insult to injury,
he then plunged into a series of questions
about a matter the judge
had already previously ruled
was off limits,
a video where Rittenhouse fantasized
about shooting alleged shoplifters,
which takes us incident number four.
The judge ruled that the prosecution
could not show a video
showing Rittenhouse saying
that he wished he could shoot two people
leaving a CVS store.
Now the background is that before trial,
the prosecution moved
to introduce evidence
of a video where Rittenhouse says
he wished he could shoot two people
who were suspected shoplifters.
The prosecutor said the video was relevant
to Rittenhouse's state of mind and motive.
He said, Rittenhouse was
"essentially a teenage vigilante
involving himself in things
that don't concern him."
Now the judge excluded the video
on the grounds that the video
wasn't made before the riots.
It was recorded two weeks earlier.
And the judge felt that in another video,
which allegedly showed
Rittenhouse assaulting a girl
who was in a fight with her sister
was also not relevant
to what Rittenhouse did
on August 20th, 2020 in Kenosha.
The video suggested Rittenhouse
had a propensity for violence,
but neither video had anything
to do with the protest.
Now it's important to note that judges
are arbiters and are supposed to protect
the rights of a criminal defendant.
And certainly, these videos
make Rittenhouse look bad,
but we aren't supposed to
convict people for looking bad.
The judge was limiting the evidence
so that the only evidence the jury heard
had to do with what actually
happened on August 20th
when Rittenhouse
encountered the three men.
Now crim law 101 is that you can't,
or at least generally you can't
because there are always exceptions,
you can't use propensity evidence
to show someone committed
a crime on a specific day.
You can show that they
committed the crime at issue,
but you're not allowed to convict them
because they had a certain
propensity towards crime.
Generally speaking, a criminal defendant
can be convicted just
because they have a history
of doing bad things.
The state still has to prove
that they committed the crimes
they were charged with.
And so when Judge Schroeder yelled,
"Don't get brazen with me,"
it was the culmination of two mistakes
by the prosecutor
referring to Rittenhouse's
post-arrest silence,
after being told not to,
and referring to the CVS videotape,
despite being told not to.
Binger felt that the
defense had opened the door
and it was now okay to go
into that subject area.
But even if that were the case,
you still need to get permission
from the judge or face their wrath.
And Binger still had a
hard time letting it go.
"This was the subject of emotion,
I'm well aware of that.
And the court left the door open."
But Judge Schroeder screamed,
"For me, not for you."
You should have come and
asked for reconsideration.
All trial lawyers know that if you appear
to disregard a judge's order,
you're probably going to get it.
And to the judge's credit,
well, we all got to see Schroeder
lambaste the prosecutors on the live feed.
The jury was sequestered away
and would have been completely unaware.
So it wouldn't have prejudiced
the prosecution's case.
That takes us to incident number five.
Judge Schroeder allowed Rittenhouse
to pick his own jurors?
Well, not exactly.
Judge Schroeder had
Rittenhouse blindly pick
the 12 jurors who would be
deciding his case out of a hat.
It's weird, but in
Wisconsin and other states,
the courts regularly seat more jurors
than necessary because
at the end of trials,
it's common for jurors to
be stricken from the panel
for various reasons.
This could be a for misconduct
or a juror having a family emergency
or just getting sick.
And the Rittenhouse trial,
18 perspective jurors
heard all the evidence.
After closing arguments,
the judge told Rittenhouse
to randomly pick
six numbers out of a tumbler.
Those six numbers were
stricken from the panel.
The 12 who were left were his jury.
Whittling down the jurors is not unusual.
Picking them out of a
hat is somewhat unusual.
Judge Schroeder said he'd have defendants
do the selection for years.
He said that responding to critics,
he started doing it after a case
where there was only one
perspective black juror.
That person was eliminated from the jury
when the clerk picked that juror's name
out of the panel.
That resulted in a black defendant
being tried by an all white jury
as a result of one of
the court administrators.
Judge Schroeder felt
that that was not ideal.
He said, "It was a bad optic, I thought.
I think people feel better
when they have control.
So ever since that case,
I have had an almost universal policy
of having the defendant do the picks.
When only one part of Judge
Schroeder's explanation
was cherry picked and then
circulated among social media,
it looked terrible.
But actually it seems like his explanation
makes perfect sense.
While this process is a
little bit theatrical,
the reasons for doing so
actually empower the defendants.
And it's hard to imagine that
there would be any prejudice
to either the defense or the prosecution
as a result of this particular foible.
That takes us to incident number six.
The judge disallowed
zooming in on a video.
Well, not exactly.
Judge Schroeder was mocked for sustaining
a defense objection to zooming in
on video footage via in iPad.
This was presented as
either a nefarious plot
between the defense lawyers and the judge,
or is evidence that the judge
was old and out of touch.
Now it's not that the judge said
that they couldn't zoom in at all.
The judge just ruled that the prosecution
could zoom in on images
as long as they had an expert testify
as to how the pinch and zoom
worked on an Apple device,
to make sure that that process
wasn't adulterating the evidence.
Now, the prosecution
couldn't produce an expert
on short notice so the jury
wound up seeing the video
on a Windows machine hooked up to a TV.
Now this was kind of a
ticky-tacky objection
by the defense, but in fairness,
lawyers are required to
authenticate an item of evidence.
And this applies to every piece
of evidence it's introduced,
including government records,
business records, photographs,
video, audio, you name it.
But look, the prosecution
has the burden of proof.
So it's on them to make sure
that what they're doing,
if they are changing
the evidence in any way,
isn't adulterating the
underlying evidence.
And of course, there was also an issue
with drone footage
where a file was smaller
than it should have been.
And that takes us to the next incident
where the judge apparently asked the jury
to applaud for a defense witness.
Well, sort of.
This one is interesting.
On Veteran's Day, Judge
Schroeder decided to recognize
anyone in the courtroom who
had served in the armed forces.
"I just want to observe
that it's Veterans Day,
and any veterans in the room?
On the jury or anywhere else?"
When no one responded, the judge said,
"Well, that's unusual not to
have at least someone in here,
but Dr. Black is, what branch?"
He was referring to the
defense witness, John Black,
who was about to take the stand.
Black is a use of force expert
who told the judge that
he had served in the army.
The judge then said,
"Okay, I think we can
have a round of applause
to the people who have
served our country."
The entire courtroom applauded,
including members of the jury.
This one was just sloppy
and completely unnecessary.
It seemed have the unintended effect
of bolstering the reputation of Dr. Black
before he took the stand,
who happened to be a defense witness,
but it was just completely unnecessary
to run that risk for a
little grand standing
in this particular case.
And then there were accusations
that Judge Schroeder was
just unusually chummy
with Rittenhouse and wanted
to see him acquitted.
For example, there's
a picture of the judge
and Rittenhouse being very close together
as they're watching a video.
But equally likely is that Schroeder
was just a relatively pro defendant judge.
And of course there's a wide disparity
between criminal defendants
who are remanded to custody
and those who are out on
their own recognizance.
Rittenhouse was able to
attend, not in shackles,
not going back to prison and in a suit.
We don't wanna make things
too easy on the prosecutor.
And maybe the answer here
is that criminal defendants
more often should get
the benefit of the doubt
like Rittenhouse did.
But more pragmatically,
if a judge doesn't err
on the side of the defense,
they are likely to see an appeal
and no trial judge wants
to, A, get reversed
by the court of appeals, and
B, have to retry a defendant.
And that's one reason why
they might err on the side
of disallowing evidence
that might otherwise come in
to make sure that there aren't other
constitutional violations.
And for better or worse,
Schroeder was clearly paying attention
to how the trial was covered.
"When I talked about
problems with the media,
when this trial started,
we're there in part, not fully,
but in part, because of
grossly irresponsible handling
of what comes out of this trial.
I will tell you this,
I'm going to think long and hard
about live television of
a trial again, next time."
"I don't know, I've always
been a firm believer in it
because I think the people
should be able to see
what's going on, but what I see,
what's being done is
really quite frightening.
Frightening, that's
the right word for it."
Now I can't imagine how he
possibly got that impression,
which takes us to the final incidents.
Schroeder had a racist
cell phone ringtone.
Come on, people.
A cell phone ringtone, really?
Come on, you're better than this.
But also, Judge Schroeder, dude,
turn your cell phone off in court.
That is rule number one.
Now there is no doubt that Schroeder
is a crotchety old man,
but maybe that's just
because his cell phone plan
is too expensive.
He's getting calls all the time,
even when he's in court.
He could have saved a ton of money
by switching to today's
sponsor Ting Mobile.
In fact, I personally
switched to Ting Mobile
and save literally hundreds
of dollars a month.
I'm not kidding.
Why?
Well, because of this.
Yes, that is a real cell phone bill
that I got with my previous provider.
And that's why I personally
switched to Ting.
And Ting Mobile has three brand new plans
to make sure that never happens again.
And all the Ting's plans
have unlimited talk and text
starting at just $10 per month.
So you can use the flex plan
and only pay for what you use,
which is especially great
if you're around wifi all day,
but you can also choose a
set of 12 gigabytes of data
for $35 or get a full
unlimited plan for $45 a month.
Switching plans is really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great too
because Ting partners with
several massive networks,
probably the very same one
that you're using right now
but at a huge discount.
They literally use the
same infrastructure.
Now I actually can't tell you which ones,
because I always respect contracts,
but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all.
And Ting still gives you the option
to just pay for what you
use with their flex plan.
Now they just give you the possibility
of an unlimited plan as well.
So if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
And it's incredibly
easy to transfer service
just by simply ordering a Ting SIM card,
popping it in and setting it up.
No phone calls even required.
But if you do wanna talk to Ting,
since they don't have
brick and mortar stores,
you can call them up and immediately talk
to real human beings or chat
via instant message or Discord.
You'll talk to real human
beings, not AI robots.
So if you'd like to give Ting a try,
Legal Eagles will get a
free $25 service credit
that could cover two months of service.
All you have to do is just
click on the link below
and give it a try.
You can even use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
So click on the link
that's onscreen right now,
or the one that's in the description.
You'll get a free $25 service credit.
Plus clicking on those links
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
check out this playlist with
all my other real law reviews
on the most important
legal issues of the day.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.